Hey everybody, Jeff here. We're doing some filming here to set up the new Google Ads.
We're going to be doing search campaigns for now on. We're going to be setting this up to be a
website search with a call-out option. That's going to be the one that's going to give you the most
utility for most of your lead gens. Maybe at a future date we'll set up a call-only ad for
specific reasons, but today we're going to do website traffic with a call-out asset added.
With that, we're going to go ahead and begin here. So I fold up my MCC here. We were going to set up
a new sub-account. You can see right here in sub-account. So when we pull up our MCC, we go down
here to settings, okay, and we pop that tab down right here and you can follow down along. It says
sub-account settings. You can see the sub-accounts right here and then I click the plus sign right
here and I go to create new account. Okay, so today for the training purposes, we're going to
go through, to follow along with the training, we're going to do Bentonville Concrete today.
So we're going to go ahead and set up an ad for Nick's Bentonville Concrete site. So I go here and
I set this up. I say Google Ads account. It's going to give you these two options. You want to choose
Google Ads account. We go down here and so for Arkansas, I want to choose their time. I believe
they're closer to Chicago time and currency. There you go and that's it. Click here
and confirm you're not a robot and save and continue. That would be the first step in setting
this up. This is going to ask me to confirm it's you. Sometimes they do that and there you go.
Looks like that was good to go. We'll go ahead and do that again. If that happens to you,
sometimes it just sends it to like your YouTube or to your Gmail. Not really a big issue.
Okay, so we have these things set here. This is your payment profile. You should already have this
set up. We've set that up for you in the training. If not, you can go up here to tools and training
or tools and settings and there is a billing area right here where you can
set that up under settings. I'm going to hit submit.
Okay, so with that, now it's going to bring me back into my sub accounts here.
You can see them right here and here is our new one Bentonville Concrete. We're going to click here
and it's going to it's thinking and it's going to come up and it's going to we're going to start
setting up our campaign. Okay, so it wants us to set up our new campaign right here. You can either
click the button right here that says new campaign or you can go down here to set up a campaign.
So I'm going to click right here and set up a campaign and then a lot of this should look
familiar with the initial training for the students that have been here for a little bit,
but if you're new, this is fine. This is just the new one that you're going to be getting.
For today's ad, we're going to be doing a website traffic ad with the call out added. So we're going
to click right here to website traffic and then here it's going to give us the different types
of campaigns. You can see all the ones that Google wants to give you or at least for options.
Google wants to give you or at least for options, we're going to select search.
Okay, and then we're going to do our website. So our website today is going to be Nick's
Bentonville Concrete. You guys should all be familiar with that through the training.
I think in the second version of training, we'll use Queen Creek Concrete, but these are the these
are going to be the same things. When it asks for your conversion goal, I just like to keep it simple
and do a page view. You don't need to set up conversion tracking at this point. This is fine.
So then it's going to ask you to name it. You can you can create whatever name you want.
I'm just going to do search ad Bentonville Concrete. Okay, when you go here, it's going to ask
on to turn on enhanced conversions. You can do that if you want. I don't because I don't like
to share everything with Google, but that's there's nothing wrong with leaving that selected
there. Okay, and then we're going to go to our next screen. Okay, so the next step in setting
this up, it's going to take you to the bidding, right. And so for bidding, its default is
conversions. I recommend and would tell you guys to go and do clicks rather than conversions.
When you start out a new campaign and you do conversions, it will Google will spend all of
your ad budget and sometimes up to three times your daily ad budget. So you want to start with
max clicks, especially for the first three or four months of an ad. So we're going to go here,
we're going to select clicks. Now the next step it's going to do is it's going to ask you
to set a maximum cost per click bid limit. You can see right here, it starts off as a default
where it doesn't ask you that. But while we're setting this up, we're going to go ahead and
we're going to click set right here. Okay. Now at this point, some of you are going to say, well,
I don't know what it is. And that's fine. So we're going to go to the next step,
which is using Google Keyword Planner to help set those CPCs. So with that, I want to show you guys,
some of you are using SEMrush. You can see here that I use Mangles. They're both great tools.
There's not really a huge difference between them. It's just that I use Ahrefs for a lot of
my SEO stuff and it doesn't work great for our local SEO. For Mangles, it's just a cheaper plan
and I like using it. It also gives me the ability to more easily search over certain cities for
keywords. So I go here. I type in my main keyword is concrete contractors over Bentonville. I get
good search volume and as you can see here, there's no CPC. But I'm not really worried about that
because I know that there are people running ads there. But it just gives me some seed words and
some other things to look at. Okay. From there, what I do is I get my main keywords. So we're
doing concrete contractors. We kind of know what those keywords are. But if you were running
artificial grass or spray foam or something like that, you want to have your base list of keywords.
And that's important in your initial keyword research with SEMrush or Mangles.
And I'm going to show you why that's important here. So we're back to our ad. We're going to
use Google Keyword Planner. Now, I don't want to lose my progress right here. So I'm going to go
to Tools and Settings. I'm going to click the wrench right here. You go all the way to the left
in the planning column. You go down to Keyword Planner. You want to right click and you want to
say open link and new tab. And you can see up here that it's open that right here. Okay. So I'm going
to say I want to you can see right here. It's got an active account. Okay. I'm going to click there
and it's going to ask me for what keywords I want to use. So for keywords that I want to use,
it's going to be concrete contractor. It's going to be concrete driveway, concrete patio.
We'll experiment with concrete company as well. Okay. So we're going to run those four keywords
for right now. You can run like four to six in here. It's not a huge thing. And then right here
where it's always going to have a default of whatever home country you're in. But right here
with the little old Google Maps sign, you want to click on where it says the United States.
And what we're going to do is we're going to deselect that and then we're going to choose
our location to target. Okay. Now this is not necessarily going to be our
this isn't necessarily going to be our main place to set up where we're going to run our ads at.
We'll get to that in a different step. This is just to set up and get an idea of what
the CPC will be for running ads over that location. So they're related but they're
separate things. So you can see here I have it selected. It's running it over Bentonville.
I could add other locations but it's really not important at this phase. We're just doing research
on CPC here. We go down to here and I say get results. Okay.
And here we go. So it's going to give us our our stuff here.
And this is interesting. We are getting no CPC here. Very interesting. Very limited CPC
for Bentonville, Arkansas. Okay. So sometimes that's going to happen. When we have here we
have concrete contractor, concrete driveway, concrete patio, concrete company, concrete
patio, concrete company and then you have the added near me. We'll talk about this when we
set up our keywords later. Concrete repair. So there's a little bit of search volume but not a lot
which is interesting. I think you guys on Simrush are getting a lot more than what I'm seeing here
right now. But we can see that in concrete there's near me. You can see a low bid and you can see the
top of page high bid. Okay. So when you set up your main keywords you want to kind of scroll
through this column and you want to pick up your top of page range for your CPC.
And this in this case the top of page bid for the one keyword will be $11.45 which I know is higher
than what we recommend in the training but when you're running search campaigns you have the
ability to be more of a ninja and getting your ad displayed when people do different search queries.
So what we want to do is we want to go back to our campaign here and we're going to set that maximum
CPC limit. I like to do one penny ahead of what I see is the highest limit.
With that we will do another additional live at one point where we will discuss what to do when
you have a lot of variations between the top of page high bid. Okay so once I do that I'm going to
hit next. Okay guys so after we set our our CPC limit we go to this next phase which is the campaign
settings. This is a really simple thing but it also can be a little confusing and if you go through
too fast with this you can make a simple mistake. So we want to be just on the search network.
We can see right here Google auto fills these two blue check marks and one is for search partners.
We don't want to do that so we deselect that and the other one is their display network so we
deselect that. Now our ad is only going to run on the search network. Okay all right and now the
default location is always going to be the world. Okay so we we're going to hit enter another location
okay and then we're going to start typing in. You can either type in a city or in this case
because I'm familiar with Bentonville and how the how it's kind of that city's laid out.
We're going to do like a 15 mile radius and we're going to type in Bentonville Arkansas and we're
going to do a 15 mile radius. Okay and that's going to give us this really big area right here
and that's about what we're going to do for this ad setup. Okay now sometimes if there's a lot of
bigger cities around here you and this city is like 170 and just by doing this all of a sudden
now my ad's running to three or four or five hundred thousand people a 20 or 25 dollar a day
budget isn't going to do well. So you just have to make sure that you do your research on the not
only your keywords and your niche but also when you're setting up your ad. If this was a large
city with a lot of suburbs around it I would just do that city and that city only and you do that
right here by going into the location and you just type in that city and that's where you run it and
you'll see it on the map. Okay and to show an example of that we'll just do that right now we'll
just show you guys what that looks like that way if you're having that issue. So right here I'm
going to say I just want to go over the location and I hit target and you can see it just outlines
the city limits of Bentonville. Okay and then now here if I wanted to add in these other towns I
could definitely do that I can add in Bella Vista Arkansas it's right here right I can add that in
too if I want to do that okay but for simplicity we're just going to do a radius because I know
that's going to work here. Okay so we're going to do this we're going to change that to 15 miles
and we're going to hit target. Okay so now we're back to there you can see the radius and now we're
going to hit save. Okay before we do anything else you want to go to location options right here
you're going to drop that down for the type of services that we're going to be focusing on for
lead gen we want to be presence and people in or regularly in your targeted locations okay
all right languages and typically in a default to english and keywords we'll get to there and
in more settings right here there's really nothing here this is where you can set up an
ad schedule if you want to set it up but typically in the very beginning we don't really do that we
don't really need to do that but you can get in here and set your ad schedule up later on
okay it's really simple you just hit the pencil button it'll give you the times all right we're
going to go to next okay so so now we're going to set up our keywords okay and this is going to
be at the ad group level okay so we're going to do and you can name these whatever you want but
this is just for me to keep track of this here's the website right here and you can see that they
wanted to give me a list of different keywords that they found okay i'm going to go up here
and you can see at the top of my screen here there's a website called adwordsrapper.com
okay it's free i don't think they try to sell your info or anything like that but what it does is it
help you format your your keywords you can see here if you want to read it you can see the different
types of keywords that are out there and there's different there's different quotes and and brackets
and other things to add and they all mean something when you load it into right here to your keyword
thing okay so we want to go here and we're going to add we're going to add our keywords so we go
here now our keywords are going to be concrete contractor okay we're going to do concrete
we're going to do concrete patio we're going to do let's see here we'll go back up to here
sorry i had to go back and get my thing so let me let me pull up some of the ones that
google's recommending right i can use some of these the near me you don't need to worry about
but maybe concrete repair will be one i want to use
okay and then another place besides google keyword planner to get ideas
is you can also go into your main goals or your simrush and you can look at the top
ones that you see here so we're going to do a concrete company we're going to type that in right
here and i'm also going to make that in plural
concrete pouring that might be one you want to look at so we'll look at that
concrete patio concrete driveway remember foundation and concrete pouring are different
okay they're going to be a different type of service then we can do residential and commercial
okay and once we have that again on these you can run eight to fifteen keywords just depends
on what you have and then you you get them to here i hit wrap keywords and then you see
it kind of refresh and then what i'm going to do is i'm going to scroll down here
and i'm looking at this box right here that says phrase match for whatever reason if you click this
button here it doesn't it doesn't want to copy it so i click inside the box here i select all
i copy and i go back to my search campaign where it says enter keywords i select all
i get rid of those and i add my own you can see the quotation so now i'm set up to run
a phrase match campaign
okay and now what we're going to do is now we're going to set up our headlines and we're going to
set up our descriptions okay this is going to be pretty much the same as the original training
but with the search campaign i get to add a lot more headlines and up to four different descriptions
okay so what i'm going to do just for time sake when you guys are learning this and setting this
up i'm just going to set up like three or four headlines and just two descriptions for you
these these are examples so please don't think that these are what i'm using or are the best ones the
best ones that you start out with always take what we got in the training and i always use those
headlines and those descriptions as my first few examples and then after that i start adding in
um of of my main keywords and and variants of that okay so here i'm going to do
my main keyword if i can fit it
okay almost there
so i'm going to do is i'm going to go here
best concrete contractors okay all right and then bentonville concrete i'm going to put experts
call now for your free let's see if we can get code in there perfect
okay we have concrete contractors we have that and what you'll see is up here you guys see that
it'll sometimes it'll want to give you ideas and it'll help you get more of your keywords that you
put in into your into your headlines and what we're trying to do is we're trying to get this
ad strength indicator we want to get it to good or excellent that's where we want to go and
sometimes it just takes a little bit of working back and forth to get there okay so we have
okay so we have concrete contractors again we have that
so we're going to go here
okay so we're going to go with those for now again you want to you want to keep adding these
headlines and you want to make it's giving me stuff here like if i click here i can just copy this
all right and i can paste that right here
almost
okay so we're going to go with that you can see the ad string starting to move so as i add these
headlines in right it's going to keep getting up to good and or to excellent okay all right and
then with the descriptions we're going to do i'm just going to stick with two of them for right now
and again i recommend that we just do what's in the script in the training okay and then you can
add sometimes it'll give you something to kind of work with here i typically don't use the
the suggested ones that google's trying to give you for the descriptions okay but you want to
take what we learned in the training that's in there in the digital steroids file and you
just copy and paste it in here and then you can just tweak it in the next two you can only add
four okay and then from here we're going to go down and for those of you that understand or learn
a little bit more about google ads there's site links and callouts we don't need to worry about
that right now maybe in the future we'll do some special videos to kind of get into that so do not
worry about those right now okay and then we're going to get into more asset types we're going
to go down and this is where we're going to add the callout feature this is adding the callout
feature to your website search campaign we're going to hit the plus calls it's going to ask
for our phone number okay we're going to go here we're going to highlight that number we're going
to copy that and then we are going to paste that number in there okay now with this there are this
is where like if you maybe don't want your client getting calls throughout the night or super early
this is where you can set just this feature up so it says advanced options you can go here and
let's say your business owner starts the day at like seven like eight a.m. so maybe i'll turn the
ads on at seven the call this is just for the call only part of the ad i'll turn them on from seven
thirty and let's say they stop the day at like six o'clock so i'll let them run to like seven
okay and then you hit save okay so that added the callout and then we go here to apply
now we go back to this is again where we're setting up our ads okay this is a big step this
is setting up the keywords and then you roll into the ads here okay we're going to go down to here
and and that's about it from here we're going to hit next and that's going to take us to our
budget okay now this is where some of you are going to kind of gasp a little bit and that's
okay google will auto suggest things for you you can see here it's funny when when you watch the
original recording of this video you'll see that google keyword planner did not give me
um much cpc options but here i am at the budget portion and it's recommending a month a daily
budget of 278 a day and it's telling me my cpc is 949 okay so there obviously are ads running
there obviously a cpc for whatever reason when we did this right now it just didn't want to pull up
the cpc details what i'm going to do is i'm going to set up a custom budget
so it wants to recommend right it's going to tell me that if i ran 222 dollars a day
i'm going to get 190 clicks a week and it cost me 1500 dollars a month that may not be terrible
if you have someone paying you a lot of money but as we're starting this out what we're going to do
is we're going to set this up we're going to try about 25 dollars a day and we're going to see what
google tells me
so at this rate at 25 dollars a day it's telling me that i'm going to get about 69 clicks my cpc
is going to be a lot lower and this is going to be my weekly cost okay now we we have the ability
to go in here and adjust this but this is a good starting point because we're going to get some
data on the clicks and the search terms that we're winning and the ones maybe that we don't want
and i'll be a separate video and we set up our budget here and then we hit next
and now it's checking for errors
okay guys so after we set up our budget we're going to go ahead and it's going to kick us into
the review page here and all we want to do is before we hit publish we just want to make sure
that we set up everything i know in the beginning i talked about making sure that you didn't
accidentally have your display ads or search partner ads click this is the place to catch that
make sure that your objective is right and i'll show you right here so we want to make sure that
our campaign name is what we want it to be so that we understand what it is later when we look back
through this we want to make sure that it is a search campaign okay our main objective for this
is going to be a website traffic ad okay our main goal is going to be page views
and then our bidding we want to do maximize clicks google is always going to want to do
it's going to set up a default of conversions i advise against doing that especially in the
beginning it's not a bad tactic after three or four months of data but in the beginning you
want to have maximize clicks we go here review our we review our networks google search network
that's where we want to be this is where you'll see if you accidentally left that blue check
mark on for the display network or search partner you'll see that here this is the place to go and
you want to go back into your settings and change that okay make sure that your location is where
you want it that it's either in a setup as a radius or as i demonstrated it can set up in
individual cities make sure that they're all here and that that's going the going to fire at the
location you want at the fire app we used about eight keywords that's fine again i recommend
eight to 15 for these you know if you have just three or four solid ones there's nothing wrong
with that if you have 17 18 19 and they're all very related and you have data to support that
that's okay too but just just for recommendations eight to 15 you're in a goods place okay the
budget is 25 a day and from there we hit publish campaign and just as a reminder the first two days
are going to be what google calls a policy review and then just checking to make sure that there's
nothing spammy or fishy going on and then after that you have a five day period which they call
their learning strategy so the first seven days of your new google ad campaign takes some time
so the data and the results are not optimal so do not stress about it do not worry about it too much
that's part of the reason like even in the beginning when we were doing smart campaigns
that's why we recommended not really messing with your ads for the first 14 days i would double that
emphasis for the search campaigns as well
and with that good luck and let us know if you have any questions